la derechista keiko fujimori y el
izquierdista pedro castillo se
enfrentaron anoche en el último debate
presidencial antes de la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones del próximo domingo en
perú ninguno de los dos candidatos
terminó como vencedor según los
analistas en medio de unas encuestas que
arrojan un empate el mico tenemos
conexión con nuestro corresponsal en
lima
seis países de américa latina están en
riesgo de colapso hospitalario ante el
recrudecimiento de la pandemia con un
millón de fallecidos la región acumula
cerca de un tercio de los muertos de
todo el mundo en las últimas horas del
domingo la confederación sudamericana de
fútbol suspendió a argentina como la
sede de la copa américa prevista para
comenzar en menos de dos semanas en
medio de crecientes contagios y muertes
por comité leasing
el partido comunista chino anunció este
lunes que permitirán a las parejas
casadas tener tres hijos nuevo cambio la
normativa de natalidad en el país en
donde se ha venido registrando un
envejecimiento de la población después
de décadas de aplicación de la política
de la política de hijo único el término
2015 tenemos un reporte desde beijing
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en france 24 gracias por
estar con nosotros mi nombre es juan
pupiales sin vencedor claro terminó
anoche el último debate presidencial en
perú previo la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones que se realizan este domingo
fue un cara a cara entre la derechista
keiko fujimori el izquierdista pedro
castillo celebrado en arequipa y con la
salud y el manejo de la pandemia como
uno de los temas principales
vengo de este espacio del magisterio
nacional preocupado por la educación
vengo con las manos limpias
vengo a decirles que soy un hombre de
trabajo un hombre de fe un hombre de
esperanza me formado trabajando todo el
tiempo de mi vida yo sé lo que es rascar
una olla para compartir y darle alimento
a mis hijos para dar alimento a mis
alumnos
yo sé barrer a una escuela donde no hay
un personal de servicio yo sé cómo es
que tenemos que cautelar como tenemos
que cuidar lo que se suda no más pobres
en un país rico
a la hora de maestro usted señor pedro
castillo con su lenguaje y sus mensajes
de odio televisión de lucha de clase no
solamente ha generado las agresiones
contra periodistas sino el día de ayer
contra ciudadanos que libremente
salieron a expresar su opinión yo hoy
vengo a dar propuestas propuestas para
sacar adelante nuestro país en medio de
esta terrible crisis sanitaria y
económica
sueño con un perú donde preservamos la
paz y no se promueva la violencia y para
profundizar en este encuentro entre
keiko y pedro castillo vamos al imán con
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
el análisis que se hace de ese debate es
que ninguno de los dos aspirantes pudo
aprovecharlo para convencer a los
electores en estos comicios que se
muestran tan reñidos
buenos días para muchos peruanos el de
anoche ha sido quizás el más flojo de
los debates en la historia del país se
sintió que tanto el pedro castillo y
keiko fujimori repitieron lo mismo que
habían venido diciendo en sus mítines de
campaña y entrevistas al paso muchos
peruanos sintieron que más allá de las
propuestas las promesas faltó el como
cómo van a hacer para ejecutar estos
planes una vez que lleguen a un eventual
gobierno le faltó la definición y se
sintió también que keiko fujimori quien
tiene más experiencia en debates pues es
la tercera vez que compite por una
elección presidencial no supo derrotar a
casilla y éste sólo se dedicó a devolver
los ataques de la derecha fujimorista y
negar un supuesto vínculo con el
comunismo porque se habla de un empate
técnico en las encuestas de esta segunda
vuelta electoral francisco
se habla de un empate técnico porque las
encuestadoras mencionan que ambos
candidatos solamente tienen un margen de
diferencia a una diferencia que es mucho
menor al margen de error de las
encuestadoras
precisamente ipsos le otorga casi un 50
y 1.1 por ciento y a fujimori un 48.9
por ciento en las preferencias mientras
que iu o pe le otorga a castillo el 40.3
por ciento y fujimori el 38.3 por ciento
mucho de esto se va a deslumbrar el día
en que se realicen las elecciones pero
ahí se va a ver que la polarización en
que se encuentra actualmente el país no
va a parar porque va a continuar un
sector de la población que no quiere a
keiko fujimori como presidenta de los
peruanos ni a pedro casi o como jefe de
estado muchísimas gracias
francisco cambiamos de tema hay más
incertidumbre sobre la celebración de la
copa américa prevista para comenzar en
menos de dos semanas la confederación
sudamericana de fútbol conmebol
suspendió en las últimas horas del
domingo argenta
como la sede del torneo misma decisión
que se había adoptado hace unos días con
colombia el certamen se encuentra sin
anfitrión y este lunes la conmebol se
reúne de urgencia para buscar otro país
que pueda albergar a albergar la copa en
argentina se registró un récord de
contagios el pasado jueves mientras que
el número total de fallecidos supera los
77 mil reflejos de américa latina una
región que vive un repunte de la
pandemia y acumula un tercio de los
fallecidos de todo el mundo para romero
nos lo explica en el siguiente informe
y la pandemia no tiene fin en américa
latina' al contrario vuelve a empeorar
con gran velocidad la región ya acumula
más de un millón de muertes
aproximadamente el tercio de las
víctimas mortales en todo el mundo y
tiene una de las tasas de mortalidad más
alta mientras que el promedio mundial es
de 46 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes en américa latina' los
fallecimientos suben a 162 además según
un reciente informe de la cruz roja seis
países de la región están en riesgo de
colapso sanitario especialmente
uruguay-argentina donde tanto las
muertes como los contagios se encuentran
en sus picos más altos
en extensión a pesar de las persistentes
altas tasas de contagio mucha gente y
lugares ya no mantienen las medidas de
salud pública que sabemos que funcionan
contra el kobe 19
quizás todavía no sabemos el impacto
completo de esta pandemia
of the standard
solo entre el 17 y el 23 de mayo los
países latinoamericanos registraron más
de 12 millones de nuevos casos de kobe
19 y 31 mil muertes una cifra que lleva
estable desde hace algunas semanas en
niveles alarmantes además la vacunación
avanza con lentitud en la mayoría de
países toda sudamérica lleva 114 3
millones de dosis de fármacos inoculadas
aproximadamente la mitad de las
administradas por solo eeuu sin embargo
las buenas noticias son que este viernes
concluyó la última fase de los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna cubana soberana y
que brasil reinicio la fabricación local
del fármaco de astrazéneca
nos vamos a grabar porque desde este
lunes en francia se abre la vacunación
contra el kobe 19 para todos los mayores
de 18 años poco más de 25 millones de
ciudadanos del país han recibido al
menos una dosis esto equivale a un 48%
de la población adulta lo que busca el
gobierno es llegar a los 30 millones de
vacunados para el 15 de junio de cara al
verano europeo y mientras avanza un
proceso debes escalamiento de
restricciones sin embargo el proceso de
asignaciones de citas para las
inoculaciones se muestra lento en las
plataformas habilitadas
la agencia nacional de seguridad de eeuu
habría colaborado con la inteligencia de
dinamarca para expiar altos funcionarios
europeos tales como la canciller alemana
angela merkel es lo que publicaba la
cadena estatal danesa de rr la
información recoge que washington
utilizó cables para desviar también a
funcionarios de francia suecia y noruega
desde la cadena de r que esto fue lo que
concluyó una investigación interna de
2015 del servicio de defensa danés que
abarcó un periodo entre 2012 y 2014
desde el ejecutivo de dinamarca tildaron
este reporte de especulación y está
fuera reacción desde berlín
y el gobierno federal ha tomado nota del
informe y está en contacto con todos los
organismos nacionales e internacionales
pertinentes para aclarar las cosas por
principio y ustedes ya lo saben les pido
que entiendan que el gobierno federal no
comenta abiertamente los asuntos
relacionados con las actividades de los
servicios de inteligencia de 7 de
como les contábamos en titulares el
partido comunista chino anunció una
flexibilización en su política de
natalidad las parejas casadas podrán
tener ahora tres hijos esto en medio de
una preocupación por el impacto
económico que pueda tener décadas de
aplicación de la política del hijo único
que terminó en 2015 desde beijing
nuestro corresponsal adrián foncillas
nos envió el siguiente informe
la medida ha sido aprobada después de
una reunión del politburó a la que ha
asistido el presidente chino xi jinping
la reforma legal se daba por descontada
debido a los graves problemas de
envejecimiento que sufren china pero los
expertos dudan de su eficacia que
recordad que en 2015 la derogación de la
política del hijo único no sirvió para
estimular la natalidad hoy en día no es
la ley la que brinda a los nacimientos
sino un contexto socioeconómico muy
parecido al de occidente las parejas
jóvenes rechazan las familias numerosas
argumentando las extenúa en tres
jornadas laborales la incertidumbre o la
carestía de vida además añade un factor
chino como ese de la extrema
competitividad de su sociedad lo que
aconseja a muchas parejas jóvenes
concentrar todos sus recursos económicos
en un hijo en lugar de dividirlos el
último censo chino corroboraba que la
población está creciendo a su nivel más
bajo durante décadas lo que anticipa
graves inminentes como la reducción de
la masa laboral o la sostenibilidad del
sistema de pensiones vamos a medio
oriente porque el líder del partido de
extrema derecha en esta ley ven el dio
un apoyo crucial el domingo a un
gobierno de unidad en israel junto con
el líder opositor añadir lápiz para
destituir al primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu echemos un vistazo más acerca
de ahora acerca de quienes ven es quien
ha emergido en un escenario de la
política del país y podría terminar
jugando un papel clave
naftalí bennett es multimillonario y ex
emprendedor tecnológico hijo de padres
nacidos en eeuu
el ex comando de las fuerzas especiales
vendió su startup por 145 millones de
dólares en 2005 y se aventuró en la
política y luego en el partido likud se
convirtió en jefe de gabinete y un
aliado cercano de benjamín netanyahu
jugó un papel importante en la política
israelí incluso después de dejar el
likud sirvió como ministro de defensa de
2019 a 2020 pero benet ha tenido una
relación complicada con su antiguo
mentor debido a diferencias personales
no ha ocultado su deseo de convertirse
en la nueva figura principal de la
derecha israelí mientras impulsa una
economía ultra liberal benet quiere que
el país adopte una línea dura contra
irán además estaba a favor de la anexión
de dos tercios de la cisjordania ocupada
en el pasado el ultraderechista ha
dejado muy clara su oposición a un
estado palestino y creo que soy el único
nuestro partido es el único partido en
este podio que se opone a la fundación
de
estado palestino dentro de la tierra de
israel entre jordania y el mediterráneo
en oposición y con la pandemia de
coronavirus en 2020 bennett amortiguó su
retórica de derecha para centrarse en la
crisis de salud moviéndose para ampliar
su atractivo mediante la publicación de
planes para contener el virus y ayudar a
la economía en noviembre de 2020 dijo a
medios de israel que el país necesitaba
dejar de lado cuestiones como la anexión
y centrarse en obtener el control de la
pandemia sanar la economía y reparar las
divisiones internas la comunidad
económica de los estados de áfrica
occidental ecowas suspendió la membresía
de malí tras el segundo golpe militar
del país en nueve meses los líderes del
bloque d se reunieron en gana para una
cumbre de emergencia el domingo en donde
discutieron sobre la crisis política que
aseguran amenaza la estabilidad de esa
nación del sahel
es el último capítulo en la evolución de
la crisis política de malí la comunidad
económica de los estados de áfrica
occidental suspendió al país del grupo
regional y pidió a sus gobernantes
militares interinos que nominen a un
nuevo líder civil de inmediato la
decisión llega después de que la nación
viviera un segundo golpe militar en
nueve meses y aprovecho esta oportunidad
para reiterar en nombre de la comunidad
nuestro compromiso continuo con la
transición pacífica en malí seydou con
el objetivo básico de restaurar el
gobierno democrático y trabajar por la
estabilidad del país y de nuestra región
la delegación del grupo regional mantuvo
conversaciones con el líder interino de
malí así migoya en un comunicado emitido
dijo que el país debe cumplir con el
compromiso de celebrar elecciones
presidenciales en febrero próximo
guaita tomó el poder hace una semana
después de que soldados detuvieron al
presidente de transición y el primer
ministro pero luego los liberaron
asegurando que habían renunciado los
oficiales habían sido nombrado
2 tras un golpe de estado en agosto de
2020 también liderado por goitá y en el
que derrocaron al presidente electo
democráticamente ibrahim bubacar keita
esta no es la primera vez que la
comunidad económica suspende a mali la
medida también fue tomada en 2012 tras
un golpe militar
si bien el derrocamiento de keita en
2020 llevó al bloque a imponer sanciones
las medidas fueron levantadas en octubre
quédense porque más mucho más en france
24 y france24 puntocom la información
continua
[Música]